if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball dodge ball came out in theaters
in 2004 and we've been quoting it since
well it's hard to believe that dodge
ball came out nearly 15 years ago let's
take a second to see where the movie's
main players find themselves nowadays
Vince Vaughn was already well-known for
swingers and old school when he starred
in dodgeball but the film marked the
beginning of a new phase and Vaughn's
career that of big-budget big-screen
comedies the next year he appeared in
wedding crashers which solidified his
status as a comedy leading man Fonz next
movies included a number of films that
he also helped to write and produce
including the break-up couples retreat
and the internship he also reunited with
dodgeball co-star Ben Stiller in the
watch tell me about yourself I know you
got a wife you have any kids how old 0
years old no kids
Vaughn later took up more dramatic work
including a starring role in true
detective season 2 he also had a
supporting role in Best Picture nominee
hacksaw Ridge
his most recent roles veered toward
family entertainments literally he
nabbed a recurring role as Chet
Stevenson on the Netflix animated comedy
f is for family he also had a part in
fighting with my family a movie about
the rise of WWE star Paige Ben Stiller
has had a varied career as an actor
writer and director in 2004 seemed like
a watershed year for him while Stiller
was already famous for meet the parents
and Zoolander 2004 saw him starring in
hits Meet the Fockers Starsky & Hutch
and Along Came Polly he has continued to
be hugely successful since lending his
voice to the Madagascar series appearing
in the night of the Museum franchise and
writing directing and starring and
Tropic Thunder he also appeared in the
Meijer with stories opposite Adam
Sandler which got a standing ovation at
can in 2017 he also moved behind the
camera and into more dramatic work
recently producing and directing the
based on a true story Prison Break
miniseries escape at Dannemora which
earned 12 nominations at the 2019 Emmy
Awards Stiller hasn't forgotten his
dodgeball days he recently organized a
charity dodgeball competition for his
Ben Stiller foundation focused around
the film Stiller was able to reunite
many of his co-stars for the promo video
which gave fans the chance to play
with him and his famous friends the game
was played live on today with the
anchors fans and Justin log Christine
Taylor had a solid career on screen
before dodgeball she was best known for
playing Marcia Brady and - Brady Bunch
movies other roles include parts in the
wedding singer Zoolander and the craft
following dodgeball she appeared in
license to Wed and more recently little
boxes Taylor has appeared in a number of
projects with Stiller over the years
including Zoolander Tropic Thunder &
Arrested Development and with good
reason
the two were married in 2000 after
meeting on the unaired pilot heat vision
and Jack the pair announced their
separation in May 2017 luckily their
split was amicable so we can't rule out
them working together again someday
Justin Long earned himself a concussion
from his characters inability to dodge a
ball but he also earned himself pretty
lofty status in Hollywood
dodgeball marked one of his earliest
roles following small parts and Galaxy
Quest and crossroads but it was just the
start for the young star he starred
opposite Lindsay Lohan and Herbie fully
loaded the following year from there he
starred in a number of comedies
including the break-up and accepted he
moved into action territory with live
free or die hard and went back to horror
with drag me to hell he also lent his
voice to the Alvin and the Chipmunks
film trilogy series as the titular
troublemaking rodent the role he's best
known for though playing Mac and Apple's
get a Mac ad campaign which ran from
2006 to 2009 Steven rout unleashed his
inner Hulk as Gordon and dodgeball thus
known for his playing Milton and office
space the veteran character actor has
kept busy since dodgeball shortly after
the film was released rout appeared in
the romantic comedy just friends root
has found himself in small parts in many
high-profile films the actor has
appeared in No Country for Old Men Selma
the ballad of Buster Scruggs and more he
also had a part in the hit horror film
get out playing gallery owner Jim Hudson
root has also had an extensive career in
television appearing on Tru Blood
24 and Boardwalk Empire in the 90s he
also gave life to two iconic TV roles
angry boss Jimmy James on Newsradio
and sad-sack bill on king of the hill in
2018 he landed the role of Monro Fuchs
handler and mentor of the titular
character on Bill hader's pitch-black
hitman comedy Barry for his work in the
show's second season rube received his
first ever Emmy nomination jewel David
Moore had an adorable love affair with
the other team in dodgeball and has
continued to charm audiences with his
sweetness dodgeball was one of Moore's
earliest roles but he quickly followed
it up with a slasher hatchet and the
much-maligned at the hottie and the
Nottie [ __ ] has also been a consistent
television guest star appearing on
multiple episodes of Bones medium and in
a supporting role on the short-lived ABC
drama series forever
sure gold 24-karat Hawaii de Lucas
please sorry you may also recognize him
from his music video appearances with
the actors starring in videos from Fall
Out Boy and Katy Perry Moore's most
notable role to date was as norm
Spellman and James Cameron's Avatar
he'll be kept busy for the next few
years with the role with Morris set to
play Spellman in all four of the planned
avatar sequels Kris Williams was already
an established actor when he played
Dwight in dodgeball then he continues to
be a popular actor today Williams
followed up the film with guest
appearances on shows like Reno 911 did
recurring roles on shows like
Californication and Curb Your Enthusiasm
he recently starred as Eddie on the
Great Indoors which was cancelled after
just one season he also appears on
Silicon Valley as Hoover the loyal
assistant to evil tech boss Gavin Belson
you'll recognize Steve the pirate if
you're a fan of sci-fi as actor Alan
Tudyk was already well-established as
wash and cult hit Firefly not long after
dodgeball
he played wash again in Firefly sequel
film serenity tunic has had many
high-profile roles with appearances and
3:10 to Yuma and Transformers Dark of
the Moon and in the final season of the
Netflix zombie comedy Santa Clarita diet
tunic replaced firefly co-star Nathan
Fillion in the role of Gary a
decomposing disembodied head you also
her tunic as the Droid k2s Oh in rogue
one a Star Wars story the actor has some
prolific pipes
voiced two huge films like frozen
Zootopia and Moana Gary Cole played the
straight man of the dodgeball
commentating duo as cotton McKnight
while you've likely seen Cole elsewhere
on the big screen most famously as bill
Lumbergh in office space
you're more likely to have seen him on
the small screen he's had a prolific
career as a guest star on TV shows like
Supernatural and 30 rock he has also had
recurring roles on Entourage suits and
beep the last of which got him an Emmy
nomination Cole is also a well-known
voice actor who has had prominent roles
and properties like Harvey Birdman
attorney at law Kim Possible and Bob's
Burgers Jason Bateman delivered some of
dodgeballs most memorable lines in his
role as commentator pepper so bold
strategy con let's see if it pays off
for the outlandish part was a huge
departure from his most notable role as
straight man Michael Bluth on Arrested
Development's few actors have racked up
as lengthy a TV resume as Bateman who
landed his first small screen role in
1981 as James Cooper Ingalls on Little
House on the Prairie he earned two Emmy
nominations and won a Golden Globe for
Arrested Development but he won an Emmy
in 2019 for directing an episode of the
stark crime drama oz arc he also stars
in the show as money-launderer marty
bird Bateman also has many major movie
parts including starring roles in the
Horrible Bosses series and game night
the late Rip Torn portrayed mildly mad
dodgeball coach patches o'houlihan in
dodgeball but Hank Azaria played the
character as a younger man in a training
video Azaria has been a major part of
some of the biggest and funniest shows
and movies of the past three decades
he's been a utility voice actor on The
Simpsons since its inception portraying
among others chief Wiggum Moe Carl
superintendent Chalmers comic book guy
and kwik-e-mart proprietor Appu in 2017
he turned Jim Brock Meyer a baseball
announcer he played in a Funny or Die
sketch into a full-length sitcom from
IFC called Brock Meyer we have run out
of cheeks to turn people we're fresh out
Azaria also portrayed Gargamel in two
big-screen Smurfs movies while enjoying
a recurring role
on Showtime's ray Donovan while dodge
ball is in a real professional sport
filmmakers managed to keep the playing
sequences as realistic and aboveboard as
possible
portraying the tournament referee in the
film's climactic showdown we've got Al
Kaplan an actor and real-life minor
league baseball umpire Kaplan called
balls and strikes for a decade as an
official before turning to acting he
first played what else an umpire in the
baseball movie talent for the game he
followed that up with small parts on
episodes of the x-files and the sports
themed sitcom inside Schwartz he also
did commercials for Toyota and Nike he
played the memorial field umpire in 61
an HBO movie about Roger Maris home run
chase at least he got to call something
other than baseball in dodgeball
following that high profile gig he was
named the head referee on NBC's
short-lived revival of American
Gladiators following small roles in SWAT
and the rundown dodgeball was Jamal
Duff's third movie and the actor played
Michel Jones
dodgeball monster and loyal
second-in-command to white Goodman tough
strikes an imposing figure in real life
to the 6 foot 7 inch actor played as a
defensive end in defensive tackle in the
NFL in the 1990s he also played for the
Los Angeles extreme league champions in
the old xml's one and only season and in
the 2000s he decided to give acting a
shot after dodgeball Duff booked to
dozens of roles in movies and TV shows
often playing bouncers guards or just
general tough guys this includes a
security guard on future man and tough
guy number one on an episode of fresh
off the boats
his most high-profile work to date is a
recurring role as Zeke on Brooklyn
nine-nine the brother-in-law of Terry
Jeffords like her on screen dodgeball
love interests Justin Long
Julie Gonzalo was well into her 20s when
she portrayed a teenager specifically
cheerleader amber around the time of
dodgeballs release in 2004 Gonzalo
played a lot of teams such as in Freaky
Friday and a Cinderella story in 2006
Gonzalo scored her biggest early career
role as Hearst college student Parker
on the third season of cult classic
Veronica Mars gonzalo is also well known
for her role as Pamela Rebecca Barnes on
TNT's Dallas sequel series along with
guest star gigs on series ranging from
Castle to CSI Miami to Grey's Anatomy
Gonzalo Lane did one other major role on
a short-lived show playing attorney
Maggie Dekker in legal drama D Eli Stone
even if you've seen dodgeball hundreds
of times you probably wouldn't be able
to pick missi pyle out of a lineup
the gorgeous actress made a huge
transformation for the part of Globo gym
player fran going from blonde to dark
brunette and adding in a unibrow for
good measure
since dodgeball Pyle has gone back to
her normal self but she's had good luck
as a character actress throughout her
career
shortly after dodgeball Pyle played
violets overbearing mother and Charlie
in the Chocolate Factory
she later appeared in gone girl and
Jumanji welcome to the jungle Pyle has
popped up all over the small screen
including appearances on sketch comedy
show inside Amy Schumer Netflix original
lady dynamite and CBS primetime anchor
Two and a Half Men check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you